what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel today we are
talking about the bachelor and why tv
relationships do not work only 14 of
couples that met on the bachelor are
still together today but why is that the
lead gets their pick of 40 potential
attractive partners and they still can't
seem to pick one that works in the real
world eighty percent of couples that get
engaged make it down the aisle so why is
it not the same on the bachelor the
number one reason that i see is that
people are clearly not there for the
right reasons going on the show leads to
money fame social media stardom and many
countless opportunities i do not see the
majority of people going on the show
looking for a husband or a wife the
majority of people probably think it
would be a cool experience and hope for
the best an example that i think of is
maddie pruitt she went on peter weber's
season and is known for famously turning
him down because she is a christian and
she could not believe peter slept with
another girl on the show i wouldn't be
able to
say yes to an engagement and continuing
to like move forward
if you have slept with the other woman
and
i'm not in any way trying to like come
across as like
judgmental or like hold something over
your head
but at the same time
like those are just those are my
expectations that i'd have in life
so just like again be very clear
i have been intimate
and
i can't lie to you about that
i just i have to be honest with you
it's like excuse me for just like a
second
just
um
that sounds nice and all but when peter
competed on hannah brown's season the
year before it was very public that
hannah and peter slept together why on
earth did matty think peter would be a
good match when he slept with hannah
brown the year before i did say there's
something that peter and i did twice
it was actually
four times
clearly she knew they were not going to
be a good match from the beginning and
did not expect to make it to the final
two so when the excuse came to bail she
did you see this often in the franchise
when there gets to be four or five
people left and they realize oh [ __ ] i
actually have to get engaged to this
person it is around that time that the
contestants that did not come to get
married leave with an excuse you see
this all the time single parents
magically missing their children even
though they really only have a week or
two left in the season and they knew how
long the season was going to be you know
obviously james is home
and
i was facetiming him
he said um
you know like
you know outside of the where are you
why aren't you coming home he said like
why don't you want to see me anymore
and um that's
i i can't focus on anything else
and it kills me because
i
see so much with us
and
i know my decision to leave
hurts you too
but right when the engagement is around
the corner that's when you miss your
kids it doesn't add up to me or you see
the contestants projecting that the lead
doesn't like them enough that they are
not ready for the engagement so that
leads to problem number two the lead
settles for their second choice what i
often see is the lead falling for
somebody that is just not quite as into
them as people we tend to want things
that we can't have so for whatever
reason the lead seems to fall hard for a
person that doesn't really like them
back that person typically stays until
around the final five some examples of
this are maddie pruitt and peter she
knew the entire time that he was not
religious but the final two comes around
and now she magically wants a man of god
you saw him the entire last season
rachel lindsay and peter where peter
knew that the bachelor is a show to get
engaged and magically at the end of the
series he's not ready for commitment
would you be resentful
no
i i would hope not i hope i'm a mature
enough person
to not look in that way
but i'm also a very emotional person
so i i can't make a promise i want
somebody who knows what they want to do
great
thing
go find someone to have a mediocre life
with why did you come on to rachel
lindsay's season where she says she's
looking for a husband it doesn't make
sense pasha and brendan where brendan is
too broken from his divorce to get
engaged
and it really breaks my heart because
you deserve a man that is
complete
um
you you deserve a man who
um
is is healed from
his past and uh
unfortunately right now i'm
i'm not that man
um
so
i'm so sorry um but he knew going into
the show the point is to get engaged my
point is clearly people do not come for
the right reason which is to find a
husband or a wife a lot of contestants
don't think they're going to make it
that far so when the final five comes
around you gotta think of a reason to
leave usually the lead falls head over
heels for that person and when the
person leaves they have to pick their
second choice from the leads perspective
i mean what else are you going to do you
don't want to beg for someone that
doesn't want you and there are other
great options on the show but i cannot
imagine starting an engagement with
someone who is not entirely over their
ex is a great starting point which leads
me to point number three you do not have
enough time filming takes place on
average for about six to nine weeks and
on average in the real world people date
two to three years before engagement six
to nine weeks is just not enough time
and the second part of that is you're
getting to know each other on camera
people act differently on camera in my
opinion there are important questions to
ask when it comes to marriage this
includes questions about politics
religion things that aren't tv friendly
and conversations that happen behind
closed doors typically if your values
politics religion whatever is important
to you don't match you weed people out
early but you get into a situation where
the lead is in love with people that
they have nothing in common with because
they can't ask those questions on camera
good looking people have a lot of
options everyone that goes onto the show
is hot and after the show everyone is
going to be flooded with attention being
on national tv leads to exposure and
exposure leads to a million instagram dm
i mean how secure would you be if your
boyfriend or girlfriend had super hot
famous people messaging them daily and
if it was you would you think about it
my final reason that the bachelor
doesn't work out is that all the
contestants are from different states
have you ever been in a long distance
relationship how did it work out for you
the majority of long-distance
relationships don't work to begin with
so they're starting an engagement
sometimes halfway across the country
what would i recommend to the bachelor
to improve the odds of having
long-lasting relationships from the show
number one have the contestants live in
the same state or one state away if they
don't live in the same state ask them if
they are willing to move to the state of
the lead half the time the contestants
don't even have a real plan on how they
would make that work number two
one-on-one time early on off camera i
know with reality tv we want to get all
the good juicy moments on camera but i
don't think that leads to good
relationships a 30 minute one hour
conversation early on in the show would
be very helpful number two have less
contestants on the show so the lead can
get to know them better six to nine
weeks is not a lot of time to get to
know anybody much less 40 people number
three try older contestants i know it is
probably good for reality tv to have the
hot young girls and guys but
realistically i do not think that either
of them want to be married so getting
someone closer to their 30s may help the
oldest lead that the show has ever had
is claire crawley she was nearly 40 when
she took the lead spot now her ability
to choose men um was subpar she
basically just picked the hottest guy
there
however you could not deny that she
wanted to marry her top choice she was
all in head over heels for him and i
think part of that was that she was
older and she was ready to settle down
now he was younger than her and he
wasn't ready to settle down i think that
if he was maybe 10 to 20 years older it
would be a different story what do you
guys think why don't reality tv
relationships work and what can the show
do to fix it thanks for watching guys
and don't forget to like comment and